4 30 a now suspended defense attorney
getting booked in jail after a DUI crash
left another driver in the hospital for
weeks eight news now investigator David
charns the only reporter in court as a
judge handed down his sentence and said
this lawyer should have known better
[Music]
a door usually reserved for his clients
but Wednesday the 67 year old criminal
defense attorney began a six-month
sentence for a crash that left another
driver's car looking like this not a day
has gone by since this off of event
that I haven't wished that I was the one
who's injured instead of you Metro
Police arresting Smith after the June
2021 crash at the time officers said he
was drunk he had gone to eat lunch
waiting for his wife to have her nails
done and he had a couple glasses of wine
as a result of this incident resulted in
him having a 0.082 Smith crashed into
Aaron moultson she spent nearly a month
in the hospital recovering from
fractured bones in a traumatic brain
injury I was 42 years old and put into a
diaper I spent my 43rd birthday
hospitalized two months later police
arrested Smith again on another DUI
charge this time they say he was driving
impaired on valium judge Ron Israel says
Smith should have known better
especially in his line of work I can't
imagine anybody wouldn't know
um
is going to affect your abilities
and certainly he has experience in
knowing that he took my dream away from
me at only 42. Moulton says Smith
changed her life for the worse the crash
putting Smith Behind Bars leaving her
with consequences too your honor I am
asking you to please send us the
defendant to prison for the crime he is
pleading guilty to I am now two years
into my sentence with many more
Moulton is suing Smith in Civil Court a
judge had put that case on hold until
Smith's sentencing his attorney telling
the court his client is broke and plans
to move in with his wife's family across
the country once he gets out of custody
I'm David charns 8 News Now
and the Nevada Supreme Court suspended
Smith's license just last week referring
him to a disciplinary board